Cuál es el proceso a seguir
Bueno después de la jornada de hoy en
donde se constituyó la comisión experta
que estaban designa
das por esta espacio va a redactar una
ante propuesta de Constitución que va a
servir como base para el trabajo para el
consejo constitucional que luego es un
órgano que va a ser 100% elegido por la
ciudadanía el próximo siete de Mayo es
importante recalcar que la comisión
experta debe tener un rol técnico más
bien el rol político y de votos lo tiene
el consejo constitucional que es 100%
electo por la ciudadanía el documento
que se genera la comisión experta no es
vinculante y se puede modificar con tres
quintos de quienes integran el consejo
además se pueden agregar cierto nuevas
propuestas
de artículos a la propuesta
constitucional de la comisión de
expertos ahora qué principios debe tener
el texto que usted espera recibir de
llegar a convertirse en consejera
Bueno hay una hay un acuerdo de las
fuerzas políticas que se llama las doce
bases constitucionales para la nueva
constitución en donde todas las fuerzas
políticas llegaron a un consenso en
donde Cuáles son digamos los los límites
acá en Chile decimos rayado de cancha de
para poder escribir la Constitución
dicho eso estos doce puntos yo rescato
por ejemplo un estado social democrático
de derecho que es algo muy innovador en
Chile pasando Desde un estado
subsidiario A un estado social
democrático de derecho
bien Y cómo está el sentimiento de los
chilenos de Cara a este nuevo proceso
Constituyente hay interés
Mira yo sé que hay muchas dudas hay
desconfianza
porque el órgano de la comisión experta
y hay otro órgano que es el comité
técnico de admisibilidad que
funciona como árbitro para que se
cumplan estas doce bases del acuerdo
constitucional
fueron personas delegadas del Congreso
ya
y anteriormente tuvimos un proceso de un
órgano Constituyente que fue cien por
ciento electo por la ciudadanía más bien
Ahora son un tres partes cierto el
órgano
consejo constitucional la comisión
experta y la comisión técnica de
admisibilidad y solamente el consejo
constitucional es quién es electo 100%
por la ciudadanía
por lo tanto entiendo que hay hay dudas
hay desconfianzas pero la campaña
todavía no no empieza al 100% la campaña
sobre el consejo constitucional para
votar por las 50 personas
encargadas de discutir y aprobar la
propuesta constitucional va a ser el
siete de mayo va a ser con voto
obligatorio y algo que que es muy
innovador de parte de chile y hacia el
mundo cierto es que viene con paridad de
entrada y de salida es decir que quienes
postulen tienen que ser mitad hombre y
Mitad mujeres y él sí mismo el resultado